please welcome captain sarah koschuba
captain wow
hi thanks for having me i'm very excited
to be here uh
okay like how did it feel when you got
the phone call
of we would like you to be the first
of a first of a first to fly the bomber
in the lead at the super bowl yeah so
it's very
humbling and very exciting so we have a
very strong
group of b2 instructor pilots here at
whiteman air force base
so to be chosen uh just within that
elite group was very exciting and
humbling and then you know
on the actual flyover day itself on
sunday as i stepped to my aircraft you
know the entire team was there
uh supporting us getting the jet ready
to go so the entire maintenance team and
support team and i just felt
such a great amount of pride to be
representing that entire team
and then the entire global strike team
as well leading both the other two
aircraft
that's so cool you think 500 missions
you've done in combat this is very
different right so when you're flying
over the big game
what's going through your mind are you
looking down to see if you can spot tom
brady what are you looking for
admittedly no i was not looking for tom
brady maybe mahomes
but uh girl i understand you're a big
kansas city chiefs fan
yeah that's our home team here
absolutely that's right
yeah so we were supporting them but uh
yeah so really focus
uh up until the last few seconds
obviously i was excited but we were
really focusing on maintaining that
tight formation and to make sure that we
were going to be on time
um but then in those those last 10
seconds my ground controller keyed the
mic so we could really fine-tune our
timing so i was able to hear
the last few seconds of the national
anthem and i
have never felt such uh pride and it was
really the pinnacle
for my passion of flying and you know my
passion for america
and uh i felt like as we were pushing
the throttles up there in the last 10
seconds
that i was just saying this is for you
america
and then we flew over and i it was just
very exciting
no sarah why does it look like you're in
batman's plane and the one to your left
is like a delta flight on its way
totally you're totally right
yeah what's that about yeah so the
aircraft on our left is the b-52
and uh that is our workhorse bomber uh
she's been around for a long time
uh she's our she's a reliable bomber
there but uh yeah we've got the stealth
and the lead yeah
there you go drop the mic that's you do
you have any advice
you know right now uh for i don't know
any woman who like maybe stressing out
there in the world
yeah absolutely so everybody gets
stressed right but uh
it's kind of two-fold how i manage my
stress my sister is actually a
neuropsychologist
so she has really hammered home the
importance of mindfulness
in the day-to-day uh so i try to
practice that as much as i can
and remind myself it's important but but
really in the execution phase
i maintain my calm just because of all
the extensive training we do
so whether it's in the simulator or
flying or studying
or mission prepping and briefing we uh
we are constantly training so when i
step to that aircraft and take off i
really fall back on all the training
that i have
uh because you know we got to make
decisions on the fly and uh
we're going very fast decisions need to
come in uh
very fast so i just really fall back on
that training could i ever come get in
the simulator
sometime to see what's like yeah
absolutely come out to whiteman we'll be
uh i will personally give you guys a
tour of the jet in the simulator
okay thank you oh my god
can i can i i want to come yeah yeah you
could come okay
and i'll like there's a little bit of
security prep that we'll have to do
beforehand but
am i correct in this um sarah that you
when you were little you went to super
bowls and
saw the planes fly over uh close yeah so
my parents
i grew up in cleveland and they took us
to the cleveland air show pretty much
every year
so i got to see not only the static
aircraft there but but all the aircraft
fly
and that's kind of where my passion
kicked in just seeing the aircraft
hearing them feeling it um and then when
i was 11 my sister
was marching in the rose bowl parade so
my parents took us out there so
yeah right right when uh right when the
parade starts the b2 does its flyover
and i had never
seen anything like that in my life and i
just thought it was
the coolest thing as a kid and it really
stuck with me
for the rest of my life what do you say
to little girls
um who may have the same dream that you
did and wanted to fly a plane
one day so any little girl or a little
boy out there that
that wants to fly think aviation is cool
maybe has a passion for it to just go
chase your dreams you know we live in
this great country where we're afforded
the opportunity to go
chase our dreams so go check it out get
into the world of aviation see if you
like it
and you know most importantly don't let
anybody out there convince you that you
can't do it
you are living proof of that thank you
captain sarah kosciuba i am just
so honored to meet you me too it's very
exciting
[Applause]
[Music]